this gonna be a short medium unless you guys have some more questions. Can we measure the about
a glutamate in the blood? No, you can't. So, remember there's a difference between glutamate
and glutamine. So glutamine is the amino acid. It converts to glutamate. It doesn't just convert to
glutamate. A glutamate just like any other amino acid is used to build proteins in your body. You
need to eat proteins in order for your body to break them down through the digestive process
so that you can then absorb the amino acids so that your body can use those amino acids to make
different proteins and enzymes. So, an enzyme is actually a protein. So, you need amino acids in order to
make those. So, you eat protein in order to obtain amino acids so that you can make proteins.
Now, to make other things too, glutamate is an amino acid that is also converted to glutamate
on the GAN genetic pathways, through the GAN pathways. So, if a person has some defects in those
GAN pathways, they tend to convert glutamine to glutamate more readily and then it can be a problem.
It can be with some people. So, glutamate is not a feeder of cancer. Glutamate doesn't
is not a factor in the cancer picture whatsoever but glutamate is a factor in other things. Glutamate
as a neurotransmitter functions as an excitatory neurotransmitter and in the braid,
it can lead to emotional issues. So, people with OCD issues, people that tend to get fixated
on something and can't get off of it, people with anxiety issues have excess amounts of glutamate
in the blood. Now, again, why would a person have excess amounts of glutamate in the blood
and in the braid? Well, it's that they may have that genetic defect on the GAN genes and they
make too much glutamate and they don't get rid of glutamates very quickly or they may consume glutamates
in themselves. Not glutamate, but glutamate. So, where would you get glutamates? Well, our food industry
purposely puts glutamates in food because it's an excitatory neurotransmitter. So, that's the science
of food. So, they purposely use glutamates, the modusodium glutamate in order to
excite your brain when you eat that. So, when you when your tongue encounters
MSG which is glutamate, modusodium glutamate, it fires an excitatory response to the brain. It makes
you think that that food tastes better. Remember, taste is completely a function of receptors on
your tongue that are firing back to your brain. So, that's why you can learn to like the taste of
something over time. It's a really a function of your brain. So, but when you have glutamate on
your tongue, it's going to fire an excitatory response to your brain and it's going to wake up your
brain and it'd be like this like little firecracker in your brain and you're going to go, oh, that's
good. That tastes good. And you're going to want more of that food and you're going to buy more of
that food. That's why you're addicted to eating Doritos and you buy them all the time because they
have modusodium glutamates in there. Now, that damages your brain when you're constantly excited
your brain because of eating too many glutamates or of having defects where you just produce
more glutamates, it can damage your brain. It can damage those neural pathways in your brain and
basically burn them out. That's the problem with modusodium glutamate. It can lead to to damages in
your brain and inflammatory processes in your brain and you know, microglial primate and antibody
production of neural antibodies and autobeaut issues in the brain. But glutamates really don't tie
in to cancer. Glutamine ties into cancer because it can be a driver, it can be a fuel source for
cell metabolic process, but that's so much glutamates.